welcome everybody to
part two of my chest.com puzzle rush
survival run this is daniel
and if you haven't seen part one which
came out yesterday i'm gonna link
uh the video in the description below
where i solved the first 25 problems of
chess outcomes puzzle rush survival tool
which essentially
is a set of problems of increasing
difficulty and you solve as many
problems as you can
with unlimited time until you get three
strikes so until you get three problems
incorrectly so as i explained yesterday
it's an excellent tool
to improve your tactics and to have some
fun
and puzzle rush comes in several
varieties there is timed puzzle rush
three and five minute versions of it
um there's puzzle battle where you play
other people what i'm doing here is
puzzle rush survival mode where i have
unlimited time to solve all the problems
and i do this so that i can walk uh you
through
the process of solving each of the
problems in order to
hopefully give as many tips as possible
about about how to get good at tactics
uh and about how to succeed at solving
problems
so in this video i'm going to solve uh
the next 15
problems in my survival run the reason i
won't do 25 again is because
the problems will be significantly
tougher um now that we've solved the
first 25 so i'm going to spend longer
explaining each problem
the other thing i will point out before
i proceed is that
i will be explaining some variations so
there's going to be some lines to
calculate and of course i can't move the
pieces on the board without actually
you know executing the solution so you
know if you're very serious about
improvement one thing that you can do if
you have a board lying around
you know roll that board out and if if
if there's a problem which features
particularly long lines
set that position up on your board and
reproduce the moves that i'm saying
that'll help you follow things
if you feel confident about your ability
to follow lines in your head then
you know by all means that would be a
great way to practice your visualization
so
without further ado let's proceed uh we
see that problem number 26 is
approximately
1400 rated level although i would take
these
rating designations with a grain of salt
you could have a 700 rated problem
that's very hard and
you know 2 000 rated problems very easy
so these are not always very accurate
now here we see that the queen is
hanging but but so is the bishop so we
see that there's two
attackers on the bishop and only one
defender but there's one wrinkle
if we take the bishop of the knight and
he takes back
it's very important not to have what i
call tunnel vision
which is a fixation on on you know one
particular thing in a position if we
take twice
um you might notice that the you know
the rook on c2 then
is actually going to be hanging at the
end of that variation so what we have to
do
is we have to first take here then we
have to take the rook first
um something that's called an
intermediate move in order to make sure
that
the rook is not hanging and after he
takes the rook now the night is free
for the taking simple problem but
nice little wrinkle in there now here we
see that it's an end game i immediately
noticed the blacks pawns are very close
to promotion so
you know if white doesn't do something
immediately such as checkmate
he's going to lose the game which
actually limits our search and that that
helps a lot
now we see that there's a rook king and
knight and all of them are at very close
quarters with black's king the first
move that i see is to capture the pawn
with check
now that is not mate the king can
actually travel to a5
and in these situations when you're
trying to hunt for a king and deliver
checkmate all that you really have to do
is make sure that you're considering
every single check so
you know assuming that i capture on b7
and i'm going to make that move because
well i see that it is the correct one
in order to aid our visualization
there's two checks in this position
we can give a check on a7 we can
actually make a draw that way the king
goes back to b6 we can go back to b7
but we don't want to rush to assume that
that's the best we can do we also have
knight b3 check
and after knight b3 track the king has
to go out to a4
and then we actually deliver checkmate
on a7 using this king on c4
to block away all of black's potential
retreat square so check
and checkmate pretty simple okay
next position material count indicates
that white is actually down a rook and a
piece
and it's the same logic as last game
when you've sacrificed a lot of material
you have to adopt this all or nothing
mentality where
essentially either you deliver checkmate
or you lose the game so
that rules out a lot of moves that i
otherwise would have considered that
might be a little bit slow
i also see that black is a very nasty
threat of giving a check on a1
and simplifying the position by trading
rooks which is
obviously not what white wants so we
essentially have to deliver a check the
first check that comes to mind
is this queen check on g6 now the king
is two retreat squares if he goes to f8
then white has checkmate by taking the
pawn on h6 notice that
both the queen and the bishop are
diagonally stopping the king from
accessing any escape squares if he goes
to h8 then i basically have the same
idea i can give a check on e5 with the
bishop
that is not the end of the story black
can actually block that chuck on f6
but i think that's a good start so let's
start with that
and now let's try to understand what
happened so there's two different two
attackers on the f6 square and there's
only one defender
and when we're attacking one thing we
want to always do is essentially clear
away any defenders
when the king is all alone it's a lot
easier to checkmate than when there's
you know an entire defensive entourage
surrounding the king so
we're going to take both of those pieces
and that was actually a crushing attack
you're welcome to go back and actually
see how that would have transpired but
white had checkmate in several different
ways there now this is a very nice
problem
because there's a lot going on here the
first thing that's going on as i
explained in the last video one of the
things you want to start with when
you're looking at a position
apart from counting material which is
equal here is identifying any
uh loose pieces and by loose i mean a
piece that is not defended by any other
pieces
i see here that the queen on d8 is loose
or undefended
and not only is the queen undefended
there's an x-ray situation going on
where black's queen is staring at
at white's queen through the rook on f6
that is a huge
tactical asset because if we move the
rook with check that's called discover
check we're going to win the queen
unfortunately a quick
look at the position reveals that we
cannot move the rook away with check but
that doesn't mean we we need to abandon
the idea
um the fact of the matter is white's
king is also very vulnerable we see that
we have a bishop on a8
that's slicing into the king position so
the move that we still need to consider
is actually rook takes f2
now of course because it's not a check
white is going to take black's queen but
if you look very carefully at what's
available to black there he can give a
check on g2
and because the king is confined to the
corner he's got to go king h1
and that puts him right in the path of
another discovered check and what we can
do with that check
is capture the pawn on g3 this is one of
those situations where if you have a
board lying around
you're welcome to make these moves on
the board to help your visualization and
we actually win back
fights queen but we do so with interest
we win two pawns while we're at it
and white will have to put a piece on
the long diagonal which will then be
also captured after we capture white's
queen so we take
we give a check and problem ends there
okay
next problem well it's very clear what
the problem is
we're under a fork so the knight is
forking our queen and rook if we allow
one of those pieces to be captured we're
going to be in trouble the other thing
that white is threatening is actually
checkmate so white has two of these big
threats
and it seems entirely outside of the
realm of possibility that we can defend
against both but
that's you know the beauty of puzzle
rush we really you know our eyes are
often open
to to the resourcefulness available to
us in many positions
and here i see that one thing that you
can do when you're under a fork
is move one of the pieces and
simultaneously attack one of your
opponent's pieces
so the first thing that i'm actually
noticing is a move like queen to d5
making contact with white's queen
but not only does that not actually stop
white from taking the rook because he's
simultaneously going to be defending the
queen he also can give us checkmate on
ea
now we look at the rook and we see that
if we move the rook away we can move it
to e3
and that achieves two aims first of all
it stops checkmate because that rook
actually guards the square
second of all it counter attacks like
white's queen so if white takes our
queen we take his and we're actually up
three pawns
so that is the way to deal with a swark
he takes the queen
we take his queen we're up three pawns
so here i see immediately that both
kings are in grave danger
probably means the correct move is a
check there's only one check available
to us so we can safely make this move
even though i don't see the entire line
yet
now when we're attacking the king in an
open board and the king is running
around we want to involve
as many pieces as possible in to the
attack
and that would mean involving the rook
with rook d8 track
and here we just need to look very
carefully for checkmates a lot of people
you know they assume that every single
move leads to checkmate in a position
like this but that's actually not true
and one piece of advice is that when the
king is in an open board like this and
it's running around
you want to actually be super precise in
terms of
evaluating whether each check is
actually checkmate and if we look at
this position carefully we see that the
king is cut off from the d
file and so therefore we can give a
check on a4 and that is checkmate
because
the king has no escape squares okay
now here i immediately see that the
queen on a6 is almost out of squares
it's only avenue of escape
is actually to go back down the a file
so a move that comes to mind quickly is
rook to a7
now it appears that that move doesn't
work because if queen takes b6 and the
rook also defends that pawn
but you know one other very important
thing especially when you're solving
tactics
and you see a promising move is not to
abandon it too soon
a lot of people they see a promising
move they see a response to it and say
ah you know close but it doesn't work if
we extend that calculation one move
further
we see that the rook on b3 is actually
undefended so what we can do is actually
shift this rook over to b7
now yes we do give up the bishop but in
return we not only take white's rook
giving us an extra exchange
but this bishop on b2 is also going to
be lost because
if the bishop moves to the first
strength the rook is going to move to
the first drink and either skewer
or fork or pick or or pick up the bishop
so
we win either the the rook or the queen
okay he gives up the queen so we're
going to take that
now here we're actually down a rook
which means we're either
checkmating black or or we're going to
lose i mean
there is absolutely zero
middle ground here now we do have a
couple of
attacking tools available at our
disposal we have a rook on the 7th rank
which means that we can actually
threaten checkmate on g7 and the first
move that comes to mind is queen to d7
it might seem like black has no defense
but in fact he does he can shift his
queen over to b2
notice that the queen is a very long
range piece it can defend from very long
distance
depending upon on g7 however this is
another one of those cases where it's
very important not to abandon the line
prematurely
and if we extend our calculation a
little bit further we can see that the
rook on c7
not only does it attack g7 it can also
um sponsor the pawn essentially in
playing c3 and cut off the queen so
we go c3 and in order to defend against
mate black must give up hit an entire
queen
giving white winning position okay
now here we have very sharp position
sharp middle game which immediately
tells me start looking for undefended
pieces
when we have so many pieces in the
center like this king is exposed
start looking for undefended pieces
maybe we'll spot a fork what are the
undefended pieces well there's two of
them
rook and bishop if we think of it that
way can we attack both at the same time
we absolutely can
queen to f3 picks off one of the two
pieces
and the problem is solved so notice how
powerful it is to always look for the
undefended pieces
um in virtually any position uh but
especially in positions where there's a
lot of pieces left on the board now
this is weird because you know the first
thing i see is why can't we just take
the rook
there's always a catch and i think that
the catch might be knight c4 pin
forking our rook to our queen but
remember what i said about force forks
are not insurmountable
oftentimes you can move one of the fork
pieces either with check
or by simultaneously attacking one of
your opponent's pieces here because the
king is weak
we actually can get out of the fork okay
by going now he has another move queen
to a3 that seems dangerous as well
that's something i didn't anticipate
he's threatening backrank mate
in addition to threatening the rook so
first question we ask ourselves can we
move the rook
and simultaneously defend against the
back rank mate and the answer is yes we
can just move the rook to the back rank
and we're up in exchange
okay next problem so we have two pieces
hanging we have a queen hanging
and we have a bishop hang so it's pretty
clear that we're probably going to lose
one of the pieces we're also down a
piece
so it seems that attacking is the only
option available
to white is there a way to start the
attack well there's only one we have to
take the pawn
now we need to start thinking because
there's two checks
well there's technically three checks
but g6 is just dumb
if we give a check on h6 he just escapes
with king g8 so that tells me
we should probably at least take the
pawn and put the king in a little bit of
a
greater danger now we can make a draw
with queen f6
but generally in puzzle rush there are
problems where you have to make a draw
but they usually occur a lot later so
that can be a bit of a hint
and another thing to remember is that a
lot of people forget
that pawns are actually very much
legitimate attackers
they only think that only a piece is
capable of delivering checkmate well
that ain't true
and if we actually appraise the strength
of white's pawns we will see that g6
poses insurmountable threats against
black's lone king so he gives us a spike
check we just taken the game is over
again
another situation where the king is in
an open board it looks like the king is
checkmated but we actually need to be
very careful here
it may appear that g3 is actually
checkmate but it is not
because that allows the king to take on
h3 and if we then give a check on h1 the
king is just going to run to g4 so that
doesn't quite do the trick
but oftentimes in these cases we have to
diagnose
why it is that a certain move doesn't
give checkpoint and here the reason g3
isn't made is because it leaves the h3
square undefended so
first thought that comes to mind what if
we actually try to defend the h3 pawn
with king h2
and we don't care about anything else
that's going on we're threatening g3
so it doesn't matter that we're down a
queen we simply go g3
and we check my block so let's do three
more problems before we pause for this
video
and a sharp position it is we see that
the king is under
grave attack here we also see that black
is up in exchange or work for a bishop
so
first thing i think about is can black
actually hunt for more material with
queen b1
and one of the good things i notice here
is that if the king moves and i take the
bishop
um you have to kind of understand how
the position changes
as a consequence of you know the last
couple of moves and here i see that
by taking the bishop we have opened up
the g7 square for our king
which means that if white gives a check
on h4 we can just drop the king back to
g7 and the king will be relatively safe
from immediate attack let's do it
and that's correct okay a lot going on
here but very important not to be scared
of these problems where there's a lot
going on because generally they can be
actually
the easier types of problems and when
there are a lot of pieces saying
you can't forget about you know the
important things such as evaluating king
safety and that's exactly what i'm going
to do here
i'm going to ignore for a second that
everything is hanging and i'm going to
look at why it's king
there is a big storm cloud around
white's king because we've got a rook
and a knight in the attack
so even though there's chaos we can
still try to
finish the attack off here and uh one
thing i'll notice is that if we do take
white's rook
then white just takes our rook with
check that's certainly not what we want
now if we take his rook then he's going
to take our queen that's the idea but
let's extend that line for a second
using the fact that the king is weak if
we take his rook
and first of all if he takes our rook
back then we just take his rook so he's
got to take our queen
and notice that the rooks can combine
and deliver a devastating check on f2
then we have two rooks in a night in the
attack and we can actually deliver
a very simple back rank checkmate it's
technically not going to be trackmate
white can give up a ton of pieces to
stop it
but that actually doesn't matter i mean
we're going to be up a night in the end
game so we're going to give a check on
e1
and now we're going to take the knight
with our rook and the game is going to
be over
last problem now this one it's sort of
an end game
but we still see that the black's king
is actually very exposed
so that tells me we need to start
looking for checks
you know sometimes people overthink
these things and okay well what move
should i start with just start with
a move and that will actually give you a
lot of insights about the position so
let's start with rook five check if the
king goes to the sixth rank
we use the other rook to skewer the
queen if the king goes to the seventh
rank noticing all of our attackers we
can give another check on d5 with the
knight
and that just seems to be devastating at
the very least we're going to win the
bishop later that's probably good enough
so after rook five the king has to go to
the eighth rank but then i see
we can give him another check on the
eighth rank draw him back to the seventh
rank
and we can use the latter concept to
force the king onto the sixth rank well
we know what happens when the king gets
to the sixth rank even if we have to
give up one of our rooks we are going to
win his queen
and at worst we're gonna be up a rook in
an end game which is
obviously good enough so there's one
more thing i just noticed
if after the check black blocks with a
bishop then he pins himself and because
he doesn't have any pawns to support the
bishop with
you know it can just win the bishop
pretty easily by playing rook to f2
doubling rooks
or by playing knight to d5 now knight to
d5 it seems to me is inaccurate because
that drops the pawn with track
so we're just gonna go rook f2 and
notice that after we take the bishop
if he takes and we take at the end of
the day we're going to be up
an entire night that end game is
actually not going to be that easy to
win
but it is still going to be winning so
here we have it 40 problems down
as you can see these are some pretty
high rated problems but there's nothing
you know terribly difficult about them
um
you know the problems start getting
really really difficult when you get to
the 50s
some of these are very very tricky even
i get some of them wrong in the 30s and
40s
but hopefully i you know as i said in
the previous video i hope this helps
the viewers sort of you know con
conceptualize how
you know good players solve problems and
as you can see it's
a lot of it it really is pattern
recognition but a lot of it
are our mechanisms and and steps that
everybody can take
when you look at a position and i hope
that i've imparted at least some of that
to you and hopefully you've enjoyed the
video as well
uh in the next video that will come out
tomorrow we will solve the next 15
problems and
well now things get really exciting
because we're in the 40s and at some
point i myself am actually going to fail
at some of these problems
but that moment hasn't arrived yet so
stay tuned for the next video i hope
you've enjoyed
this one um and as usual i would be
honored if you subscribed uh for more uh
instructive content and uh feel free to
comment
uh constructive criticize in the
comments below and i look forward to
seeing you
in the next video thank you very much